ladies and gentlemen we got him
[Music]
question time yeah now you can answer my
question be running the run your mouth
yeah now you tell me where the sooner
they get a proper camera from not listen
Kaiser wait I say one for your book you
know your I was able to walk a bit
lately
yes yeah in your friends book you said
email put to me you don't know put to me
this even if you're the first I can I
mean you're beep I'm gonna post
everything I'm gonna post a Arriba
you're bad are you know with hot was
reported missing on so much eponymous
everything was I was going mister yes so
you was not me that's it back so you
revert back to your mama died name is
near benefits vary among that the
Muslims say irrelevant so you're not
recognizing your mom with that already
miss well no it's not really buy
anything
so you mechanisms my money today so you
back tomorrow in fact new Virage your
mama that sex as he no no I mean let me
make my point my point is what when you
have no comment on sex
this is Ali Troy watches you got myself
do you
no tell him listen so he won't be
battles as followers of Islam hey Rick
no sir now you've asked for reason yeah
the people who follow you man that stays
under Islam yeah are murdered and
terrorized and horse neighs by him as
opposed by radical Muslims because they
don't recognize what they do what you're
doing they do not they do not recognize
that another group of people who follow
Islam yeah
all Muslims do now you just six that's
why you quit several rebirth then a
member cusan listen because if you're
writing no fact I'm able is Vitoria
ppang clean majority people okay listen
any point though my point is you don't
even my mom my dad my granddad my
grandmother I read to you mum to point
us back not your mom you call yourself a
river which means you don't accept your
mom and dad has been Muslims or dreamers
names okay and because of that yes
frosty Islamic world yeah Muslim got
being murdered look like look at the
demo because if you decide what's good
but because I'm huge what's Pegasus
because he doesn't recognize him yes
follow Islam because they viewed as
apostates and when as evil want to kill
them now you just read you just told me
you don't make the noise your mum that's
interpretation of Islam as the opposing
repetition they're not Muslim no you
know they'd work there the dough from
the save your M&MS are you okay the
sexual moment that you set your mum to
follow my dad does not follow a set my
dozen agnostic see listen listen you
said therefore I your ideology that
means my mum is at one my mom and dad
isn't one Muslim I should kill them oh
no oh you know I say every single Muslim
okay which one go off them opener you
work with over five
I swear I swear you can oh I'll tell you
what the hotel they are the reason why
Joe Kraus computers having you other
reason why darren rowse will run over
innocent people
Isis New Zealand I slows the reason or
spawn it was okay if anyone remembers
below I condemn his will
like all you just say I condemn fishbowl
are as a terrorist organizations message
so do you support I know your support
please go ahead I'm gonna go to the same
thing can you show me where anyway live
in most negative ways Lamia innocent
people can you show me a single verse
I'm just asking a question
Tomi is the one who wrote a book called
why Muslims kill boys laugh I went with
that book in that book he says in Islam
murder means kindness will help
I've listened to you listen to me this
one to shout over each other kids
understand so I'm asking for this this
is why I'm asking for you Isis you are
running over innocent mode non-muslims
on the streets
now you're okay anyways I'm asking for a
single person of Quran in the hadith the
in highest affliction that says and even
in under a minute
the says Muslims for you guys to be a
good Muslim and die as a martyr the
golden hat do jihad don't kill innocent
people you see how he so focuses on the
word innocent people because his view or
Islamic world view of innocent would say
okay tell me one thing why don't you
tell me how tell me how Muhammad may his
wife's appeal
tell me how he missed my Sophia let me
say things like a blow in the bathroom
high bar and buy so hybrid the trees
were plotting to kill the Prophet and
you also said go go don't go
you said the perfect cool 600 G's yeah
the Prophet had h80 a treaty which said
that they will respect both parties the
Mo's didn't respect the Jews and the
Christians and he will live in harmony
but there are three tribes most majority
of the Jews stuck to the treaty three
tried trying to assassinate the Prophet
he excelled them the second one shot
inside the cafe he imagined the husband
was killed
listen your phone above these bubble
yeah this is a lease for watch I will
come to you wherever you are I was gonna
catch me that red thing you know in red
listen lady with issues but listen
listen okay so your profit on the same
noise are from the same night that he
killed her husband and their brother he
then married oh that noise yes so you
think she's willing willingly married
him
yes you think she will agates so a lady
yes whose husband was murdered her
brother was murdered over headed wife
wife right welcome look at this guy
story the poor guy so why now you behave
well Wade your work that's a proper you
think your prophet so you don't think
you'd probably break that no way dude I
think you probably don't wait I said
right where'd you get that from
Pete Mary doesn't follow me anytime see
that said he got raped you married
Eleanor mean he's sick so I shall have
to Hanoi can you show me he had other
night when you get married you have hey
pink said I really don't know any when
you're married but when you marry you
have intercourse what's that to do it
killing man could he make murdered her
husband her husband while hi why why cuz
he surrendered this Mendeley surrendered
I memorize in the muscle hey buddy are
sharing a castle yeah a bit and the one
gentleman was it was in Atlanta just one
second when you go to you vitro roses I
go guys alright okay II go so honey when
you go and see these Isis responded
right cause we're gonna see these Isis
combats who in my name produce on me
Isis is a bigger danger to me you know
you know you challenged jihad jihad is
when Nazi Germany when Massachusetts a
Christian did missile progress in charge
so it's no more thank you for the bumps
what did--what implemented Brinson came
and defended their so yeah so don't
continue with this nonsense you same way
you murdered her husband and her Bravo
and you think she willingly married her
him
that noise you think either you think
that he really doesn't mean she didn't
do you mean any woman
yes example he said yeah okay anyone who
doesn't so don't talk to me about what
they said you fellas how you support
them so there's a connection between on
a support brimful you do know I miss you
do know I don't you said Katie they're
having a trial today
make some praise for them no it didn't
you could think another side same except
ready no they believe in fairies in the
story no I'm asking simple questions
please show me where it says kill
innocent people that's what I was
trained I know Miyoshi
after my husband on the number one
yes fly by the heavens yes animal yes
yes continue with the bite hey fix my
almond right sir heaven on the wings
okay so why are they so we get all the
scripture and the evidence we give up
well understand lolly be instructed to
kill that's what we do okay can you show
where it says we must with the kill
innocence well it's ringing instance
again I'm Kate I'm a Muslim show me
where he says spoke to innocent people
and I'm going oh you're here shortly
listen I'm you show me that where
wherever we in Seoul
now I have to yeah how nice
humming uh sex yeah when she was nine
yes do you believe that was it
whose opponent Mary I shall not sit and
watch maybe that knives now about my it
means right
okay according to him he's a imagine how
much he had is a nice people can I sit
up Adobe they showed me a new dog
mahogany back like don't finger man the
sinks sleeping anointing boats plane
animal been exposed
what Tommy is doing is this is comparing
explanation now in this country and in
this country now in this country
two days ago 100 days ago in this
country one screen you're gonna see the
legal age to get married was seven years
old now the question is wrongs micro
once again if a woman in a bikini listen
like 1400 years ago what happened to
what we've Muhammad around Ypres Libya
hydrorite okay unless he knows around
Roman Empire
well what I'm did it what dissolving or
throwing a mystery or lifted I don't
believe in this choice I live in history
oh yeah he wasn't it was evil person
because you Penelope was it mr. face so
you
so if he made her
okay so
proven is that he believes
winning
it's a rapist of terrorism he says when
you look at the way be emotional Muslims
go join Isis there is no connection
between their religion and what they're
doing that's the one yeah so the guy
Isis member sarahx he goes how many
people did you rape he was already 200
and the lady said why did you do it
because I'm poor I need money for my say
yes it was before you without nose born
yet you got heated yeah you stopped
crying about it you stop lying about you
radicalize that was born
just the way to engineer outside the
crisis you just make your statement yes
either cause we're gonna show the end of
it oh no and we need it what did he
tweet I mean what did it take the letter
then you tell me you're the one it's
alright that's 11:30 they check this
iPhone it's his wife said he was so it's
below I described Terry's may be
noticing or you said I'm at a point in
my sanity response yes that March and
his Harris localization flagship
sponsored you know what do you find a
senator
prescribed terrorist organizations like
this for which he's in his book what's
the definition of terrorism I said this
is the same man you got something
mentally disturbed kid yeah oh then the
content is low yet we're calm textbook
what's the difference
you talk about banking on a baby brother
I'm going to add this paper called a
book in your library to me so tell me
we'll keep it as a tree yeah let us find
smile actually but you know that she's
gonna bat phone you know why because
over there this one is context yeah I
context you know I think you know what
I'm gonna go kind of you know I'm an
atheist I see to them back if you just
hold the phone she's going you know okay
has a right to remain silent yet I'm
having a debate so we're going to be
transient to their worldview because you
show must defeat you over Abby
this is my with anybody anybody that
comes to this country and I these
passports and this country so for here
or born in this country
Ali who has this passport and runs
people over is stretchy it is stretchy
stomach booting choices buses and
growing up trains or buses one of it may
be anybody that carry this passport and
runs people over or less baggage quote
oh no I'm a proud British Muslim and I
love this country and I'm doing this
video to expand Islam's first light
Sharia comes before Shamir comes before
does that mean okay but does that mean
it comes first does that mean others to
be this nice lady understand lady calm
examiner shamea comes a corporation
alarm comes to friend
I know it's pretty boy
this man's looked into one mosque look
in front it watch it honey
not long after won't grooming gang look
that one single thing about confronting
genuine problems in your damn your
commune
why not why why
buddy is murdered in full what is the
argument because he is a pasta so cuz
he's the post by the law changes yeah
they should be punished not you Dustin
but do you believe
anywhere in the world
okay brother
you kidding me man believe I'm seeing
you once again country it shall be
Arabia Saudi Arabia which are allies you
in America
yeah in that country if you wait woman
to punish get a storm even if it has to
become poor which is what is not
coincidentally stand up no is she a
woman
no no no punish with the century why did
you punish normally you would before my
gosh I did not see that we should get it
instead of questions what it was I'm
late is difference it don'ts me if
you're married and you chew on your
fingers right let me finish
because
yeah yes get done
do you agree with that one so I believe
you got room in Cantonese yeah I feel
come back to me mate greatly to go
between alcohol haram you rape your
haram you call clubbing haram what'd you
do what'd you do in setups in the file
honey look at me what'd you do me show
me show me show me show me
you're gonna show it to me what I just
like and I mean I listen just so expose
him just so it's black and white people
to hear can you get what's up to me the
money get will you will you condemn
people be murdered in Islamic countries
for leaving Islam where we condemn them
that's the law
I have it I look like I will and I'll I
want - hello - who you feed em it look
below if you're sure this is it's a fun
wigs so Sharia says kill them if I have
no I believe if she raised a sec so
listen legal age for six honey tell us
what you think the legal age sex be I
don't want mine uh what to use them
believe me like not me not me all right
so should we have 3 min to decision is
giving us illegal items to legalize on
this reel see that's not age you can
arrange several memory 19
Winslow okay no if she's with choices
that you can make decide you see visual
yes and at the side so if there's a 12
yo girl who started pooping which type
you be could she be okay to have sex and
demerits if I'm sorry when you go on
google and write what is a child you can
see like no and ago it says that anyone
we decided so you want an adult but that
doesn't mean I'll get my daughter
okay darling it's time for you to get
mine man no housing you will get married
No
then you don't get married so all
marriages are higher ominous the I are
super cozy life is magnetized on some
new york with the first day i answer
other than my own your beautiful
wheelchair I don't know you why you to
see the world when you want to see well
when I saw is quite be okay it's under
Sharia no it's time to show you maybe
you'd like I'd like to see how the [ __ ]
but you'd like to see okay budgets are
under your Islam you'd want to see who
makes that you know me getting for the
same parents you don't even play do you
not see I'm so nobody no laws or under
your perfect world a parent couldn't hit
his friends no I'm his daughter
yeah she waiting in this room I'm asking
you must've come in and add a new but
very puts I'm asking you I'm losing it
tell me tell me tell me tell me what the
leads Asian hoc listen tell me what he
gave me in a widget would you need one
is she
no okay as we know in this country so he
believed of his finish he's exposing we
believe I told you guys I'm with a
Clinton highest northern guys and I told
you guys I told you that anyway good
anyways and he's been answered he's
gonna be more people should be why
wasn't real islam ago guess he's on
first do you think one everything worth
shootin yes because other monks how did
you find more step I'll find it was she
[Applause]
people would be punished and murdered
for leave this on peep men would be able
you have sex with children a place if
they believe that you bought the book
but slide wasn't cooking it up a sting
boomers please
I struggle
yes oh yes no I'm never gonna forget
this are these days what about
anniversary for you they're hungry
you never know
me something watch what happens on
Monday you see a statement where you
misstatement coming out yeah see what
boy next toilet no you see it and then
you'll understand I could sit down and
see what you're seeing
hey bud shake hands in a Green Wave in
here learn have an official date for the
baby by camera now okay so again maybe
just some money day's events waste in
today's events alleys come he's exposed
that in Islamic countries he doesn't he
thinks people it's acceptable to kill
people who leave Islam he's exposed he's
exposed and that is okay he all the time
and this is nothing between our scene
and we also need one single Muslim on
their radical jihad is them all even
though you read about all the moss run
through the noise
timing right Ali
okay I've been looking for this guy for
two months yet I was waiting I was
waiting for him again he's been claiming
he wrote a whole book on let's go
why then all the best you know I
yeah we're just talking about you double
date yeah I know I saw that oh yeah my
friend Wally's a combat okay she's from
Essex but I'm gonna agency always watch
the video okay
yeah remember what Steve said oh you
don't know her this remember all right
huh ones that ask you a corner and I
know that this is speed yeah so yeah did
you suggest a wrap up guys that'll set
you before you look all I wanna do is
debatable when I wanted to we asked him
question yeah because you claimed things
and we get any some people getting
killed right because when you start
seeing Muslim this Muslim that moves in
this was that people are stalking it's
not happen in Nazi Germany use the lab
excuse a bath use it is you turn them
into a bloody monster so then what
happens innocent people get killed this
is why we should fight he and he
[Music]